start with the travel chaos whose fault
is it well i think it's a combination of
everyone's fault but it's quite clear
the government had been asleep at the
wheel
i think yesterday the transport
secretary was spending most of his time
phoning around conservative mps trying
to get them to support the prime
minister then doing the job that he's
paid to do but it's quite clear that the
travel industry has been in trouble for
some time in terms of trying to recruit
staff and we were saying a way back last
year when restrictions were being lifted
and furlough was coming to an end that
those industries that were hardest hit
and longest to recover needed more
support and didn't get any and this is
the consequence of that
not directly into making sure that they
could scale up workforce that could
retain the staff that they require that
they were paying people
properly and look the airlines take a
huge amount of responsibility for this
there's no doubt that for example
british airways who were hiring and
re-firing were filing and rehiring
and all the issues they've had over the
last few years with pensions it's very
difficult to recruit staff when you're
doing that to your own staff at those
times so there's blame of pushing
everywhere here but in terms of the
government's role they need to bring
people together and to step in and do
what they can to help and my own airport
edinburgh are asking the government to
not relax the rules in terms of security
go to go either side but to make them
quicker so they can get staff onto the
front line as quickly as possible so
everyone needs to come together here now
to try and resolve this problem because
families holidays are being ruined and
we can see that from the pictures on the
sky over the last few days you mentioned
uh grant chapston what you might might
not have been doing yesterday we heard
from dominic raab whose deputy this
morning the prime minister's deputy
saying there's nothing to see here it's
everything's fine
well everything's not fine because the
government's paralyzed by this issue and
have been for the last
five or six months now and you see the
report also today from lord guyt who's
the advisor on ethics to the prime
minister who got his job because the
previous incumbent resigned over the
prime minister whitewashing a report
into bullying in the home office and
he's saying that the prime minister is
ridiculing the ministerial code that he
has to come out and explain why he
doesn't think he has to resign because
he's broken the ministerial code all of
the things are just dominating our
politics at the moment when you have
travel chaos and when you have a cost of
living crisis it's the worst in a
generation yeah but the government's
come up with 15 billion pounds to try to
help with with that is what they would
say in response well they would but it's
too little too late for many and every
every penny is obviously welcome but
they've they've actually had to come up
with the ideas that they've been
ridiculing labor for since january when
we came up with the windfall tax tax and
oil and gas companies to help people
with their energy bills and to do
everything they possibly can for the
cost of living crisis but you can see
what's happening at the moment
everyone's spending their time in
government trying to defend the prime
minister we may or may not have a
leadership challenge
next week we've got a prime minister
who's really a lame duck and the only
way to resolve any of this issue is for
the prime minister to resign and to
replace him with someone who can bring
integrity back i mean he's come up with
15 billion quid which is more than
labour uh had suggested when you were
asking for the windfall tax and he is
also being lauded by the president of
ukraine
uh well there's
the country's been at war before
involved in wars before and changed the
prime minister but we can see that this
isn't dominating our politics there is
no integrity left
in downing street you can see that from
the sioux
grade report what the prime minister
wants to do is to drag everyone else
into that political gutter with him so
he can say that luke everyone's the same
and therefore i'm just the best of a a
bad bunch that can't be allowed to
happen kirsten has made it pretty clear
uh what should be happening uh with the
prime minister and while she remains in
office the entire integrity of our
politics is diminished i'm glad you
brought that up um former director of
public prosecutions being basically
questioned under caution
well there's been accusations made don't
forget the durham police said last
february that there was no case to
answer they've now opened a new
investigation they're going through the
process of that they'll come to a
conclusion from that and any sanction
that may be required kirsten was
perfectly confident that he was abiding
by the rules and he is clear about that
he was 350 miles away from home during
an election campaign in a constituency
office having something to eat it's all
been pretty clear what the case is that
he has
laid out and he says that it's up to his
own integrity but also the integrity of
our democracy that if he's given a fixed
penalty fine like the prime minister got
he will step down but nevertheless i've
returned to my original point which is
he's the former director of public
prosecutions and he's
being questioned on a caution uh well he
doesn't think that he's done anything
wrong the police are duty-bound when
accusations are made to investigate they
are investigating part of that
investigation is to send a question not
always the people involved do they feel
like that question always they only do
that if they think there's a case to
answer well they're investigating the
accusations that have been made mainly
from uh much of the uh media and indeed
conservative mps who've made this these
accusations so the police have already
just been clear are you suggesting that
it's the media's fault that he's that
he's in the position he's in no i'm
suggesting that they started the story
for the reinvestigation the police are
then duty-bound
to open an investigation to reassess
this they're doing that through the
processes and uh kirsten has been pretty
clear he doesn't think he's broken any
rules and if he has he will do the
decent thing and he will step down and
that's not just because he's leader of
the opposition and believes in her
integrity in our politics but because he
has been a former director of public
prosecution and it didn't help that
labour lied about whether the deputy was
there or not well i don't think it was a
a lie i mean lies doing an awful lot of
heavy lifting there this was an event
that was happening
in durham there was a schedule of
attendees and there was a schedule of
what was to happen
there and everyone's pretty clear that
no rules were broken and
but we were told that she wasn't there
and she fundamentally was there well
to categorize that as a lie though is
well
a mistake and people weren't sure what
who was there i mean it's all the shape
it's all come out
now and people have said well
the investigation will now happen these
sheets that you talk about incidentally
are no smoking gun every single visit
from any shadow cabinet member have a
shared job
they must have looked at that and and
then made a decision to say that she
wasn't that way fundamentally yeah on
those sheets that also said quite
clearly what the covert rules were and
compliance with those covert rules
that's pretty clear because it's in the
public domain which shows that this was
a pre-planned uh work event the stopping
for food was part of that pre-planned
work event and the cover drills were
part of that
schedule and that's why i think that the
police will come back and say that
there's no case to answer and kirsten
was quite confident about that but he
has said and i think it's right for him
to say this that if he does get a fixed
penalty notice like the prime minister
did he will stand down because he
believes in integrity and public life
why do the good people of glasgow not
want to have jubilee celebrations do you
think
no parties at all well i don't know and
it's great in my own constituency
there's roads closed everywhere over the
weekend for people to have street
parties and come together it's yes it's
the jubilee but it's also a great
opportunity for after two years of
covert and lockdown for people to
celebrate with their neighbors to come
together to socialize to bring their
children together i think it's a great
thing for the country to do people can
make their own decisions if they want to
celebrate the jubilee but isn't it just
a great excuse to get people back
together again after the last two years
would you celebrate a ukraine victory
over scotland tonight well that's a very
difficult question probably not i mean i
wouldn't be as disappointed ordinarily
in a scotland defeat perhaps tonight and
but i do want scotland to win but i
think it will be a wonderful occasion i
hope the occasion is marked across the
world for what it is and sends a very
strong message to what putin is doing in
ukraine but i won't be as disappointed
as i would perhaps normally be but i do
want scotland to win this okay good to
talk to you thanks so much for joining
us thank you